[Music]
in sexy time you committed by summer
lovin a college is now offering a class
of sexual happiness with topics
including sex toy product knowledge not
mugging gyrating on the [ __ ] chair
bro isn't officially moving that getting
here to go click click click click click
this is a college class yet look clack
clack
that's kind of cool yeah it's a college
course about hopefully mm-hmm and sexual
happiness so this college is now
offering a qualification in sexual
happiness and it's also partnering up
with the sex toy retailer named love
honey by the way this college is in
England it's called bath college back
College fat
bah yes the funny name is that it's
really funny yeah and so yeah we get to
learn about sex toy products
sexual health issues and sexual identity
what is sexual identity I give you
consider yourself heterosexual
homosexual Oh thought it was like I
considered myself a male but I come like
a woman what like a woman come did you
it's only when you're coming you
identify as a few yes as a sexual
identity it's how you regulate my
regular identity I'm a writer and I'm a
man but when I have sex I'm a mermaid
that loves to I don't know but uh yeah
they just think no I feel like this next
generation um you guys are so [ __ ]
because you have cetera yeah you know
like growing up to like you didn't have
to think about what the [ __ ] you were
you just were what you were yeah I mean
I think like it's not a bad be a good or
bad depending on your perspective but I
was kind of joking around with this
yesterday like you know how you have a
lot of aggressive human beings like at
that time for us right now the
regressive human being is not
acknowledging that homosexuality exists
right but I feel like so the next
generation is going to be parents who
are like kids going to come up to debt
and be like again so it turns out that
I'm actually a girl sex club I want you
to just be gay but just because like in
Seoul it's progressing like in that type
of direction now so I wonder it what's
the next thing what's the next thing so
I wonder if the progressive parent now
whatever that definition is is going to
be considered regressive with the next
step it's always going to change yeah
there's always going to be something
else that's like shock shocking and
they're gonna be like he got I'm
actually a girl but I like guys I know
that way so you're gay I know it's
because I'm a girl so I'm actually
straight but right now biologically I am
Giggs I have a dick and I liked it but
the post surgery it's going to be
straight and so you didn't have these
crazy-ass complicated conversations that
you'll even know what the [ __ ] your kid
is saying or some turn on the TV
thunderstruck game a couple obviously
just see your game and like easier for
me good
I identify with being a female but I'm
also a lesbian so I love females but I
don't want to operation so I still like
girls yeah I was like what is going on
in this world man
it's kind of like going in and out and
you got two choices but now it's like a
Hong Kong cafe where you don't even know
what to order anymore cuz there's like
600 things oh my god Chinese menus are
so hard the thing is there's 300 things
on a [ __ ] menu and they expect you to
choose within the first three minutes
come on man I'm not even done reading
the whole thing yeah the fun restaurants
the best though well right when you walk
in what do you want to order so can I
get the menu first they have it in their
hand you want to hold a plug bro no way
you want yeah but you better actually
already know what I want them isn't that
late getting a nice food I know what I
want yeah automatically right when you
sit down egg roll uh no tendon meatball
thank you
soda Chuck thank you okay I kind of miss
how did we go from sexual identity to
spa confusing Vietnamese people are
freaky
so really the same there's so many
choices now it's kind of like a Chinese
instruction whereas before back in the
days like just like in and out you get
it either the single or the double
double and that's it
because we had that conversation with a
friend of ours where she was talking
about how she had a niece and then her
niece at a very young age said that I'm
a boy
right so the mom wants to be super
progressive like hey from now on we're
going to call him this name blah blah
blah blah and then she said that she was
going to have a bridesmaid party or
whatever but then the kid got upset
because he wasn't invited
it's like but it's a bridesmaid thing so
girls only allowed and we're supporting
your decision well I guess I want to be
a girl now it's like what a lot it's
like you know I mean so now it's like a
choice where I think certain people are
kind of concerned it's like is it just
like a young being when they're trying
to find themselves maybe let them
breathe a little bit and I think it
although they can make that choice
because there's people that say that
they don't even want to choose right the
right in the middle yeah people copying
that not I think no asic androgynous
moving on with it smooth I thought it
was really a fluid yeah so they're so
those are the people just trying to like
take advantage of both sides you want to
be the groomsmen and bridesmaids yeah
they get the best of both worlds in like
years ears ears ears ears in the future
like aliens visit our like tight with
aliens and others that want to be aliens
like no time not consideration I think I
want to identify as a girl and fight MMA
and um yeah and I'm going to identify
with a different weight class okay I'm
going to identify with super light have
super lighter it's a feather hot super
lightweight there is a mixture mixed
mixed martial arts fighter that was born
a male and only until recently he went
through the sex change to become a woman
and he wants to fight women and he's
like well I'm a woman you're
discriminating against me saying I can't
find as a woman's like no you got all
the physical benefits of being a male
going through puberty and everything
else and of course you're [ __ ] up all
these women if you like destroying them
and these are getting upset that not
letting me fight because I'm uh because
I'm a what transsexual or transgender is
like that's not the point
yeah it's that's the case then where you
can just fight men what I want to say is
like if you want to fight then I guess
but does have a wee-wee
No so yeah yo who do you fight that you
can only fight when I get out but then
he's already like the strength of a man
like some women who have competed
against him there like it was insane
it was like wanting to do never going to
win anything it's pretty complicated
these days yes mama Jennifer say this
next generation did you guys have so
much more problems or like things to
think about and all I had to think about
was either not getting arrested getting
my ass [ __ ] up or you know not getting
[ __ ] up on my parents is it yeah it's
crazy but anyways yeah this college is
offering this qualification so we're
going to qualification before so it's in
sexual happiness so that's that's all
they really like the extent of the
explanation of it because I was trying
to figure out too like what exactly is
it what sexual happiness so what they're
teaching though is it's the whole sexual
health issue sexual identity and sex toy
product was just a sex ed class a sex ed
class that's also being like content is
satisfied with everything that's part of
the secretary class and yourself seems
like yeah it seems like that like I know
what my sexual identity is I'm
comfortable with that I know the toys I
know this stuff like that yeah and I say
that there were ten participants and
have disqualification not they went
through that course and they work in
areas of the business including like
customer care HR marketing online trade
sales and buying and content so that's
what they are involved in the people I
got these qualifications that's cool
that's really cool not like an
extracurricular yeah kind of like a
certificate like I passed this course I
think they should have a course that's
like sexual mastery where they always
have the same amount of partners and
they team up and then like the girls
Jack the guys often and the guy rub the
girl quit and in the engine stood the
teacher okay you guys are sexual masters
that's a real certificate to they should
oh my god that's so genius because I
just pictured like you can have like
like like contestants like professional
athletes athletes there's sex athletes
right so like this one is it's like
animate you like this one
calm down you're too excited cutter I
get it can you get it out so it's like
you had your contestants right I like
free Jefferies man I like contests he
has a record world breaking finger bang
like Oh make any girl come when you
learn from him like yeah like whatever
like and there's different skills like
this fools got a gold medal and
cunnilingus and then this girl is like
[ __ ] skills are off the [ __ ]
chain and it's like MMA you could watch
these matches it's like porno right Oh
best [ __ ] with the best [ __ ] and see
who's gonna make who come first and what
technique they use and I would go ahead
my idea pornhub I feel like they might
have some use because I have something
like that problem I've never seen it I
would have been you imagine a girl and a
guy 69 in and then the challenge is who
can make who come first yeah I don't
like that because then it removes the
passion out of it your apartment look
like the vid about it there's a to you
if we look up right now online like
competitive [ __ ] or content like let
me go to another see you're missing the
point because you don't know there are
wrestlers you're like come rape [ __ ]
race or something like that I'm Ted
competitive fun you know what I'm
picturing I'm picturing like like
somewhere in between MMA and figure
skating Oh what so so like the figure
skating part is like the sensual like
artistic side of it right but MMA is
like the toe to toe competitive side
where if you just have like this dance
battle between the two but it's a [ __ ]
battle and I'm thinking of the marketing
behind it you know in the fights they
always have backstory yeah I'll [ __ ]
that fool up so I'll be like the guy
will make her [ __ ] like [ __ ] crazy
I've been making girls come my whole
[ __ ] life and the girls like oh my
can't [ __ ] come all over my face
there has to be definitely people who
are like more hyper sexual where there
it's just the physical act is the only
thing that they need like not me like
they're like sexperts you know maybe
maybe the whole part of sex so
aggressive we can move you know no
you're missing the point that's
something you have to do the inside you
know the inside videos yeah
some use of us fight was a courting side
because it could even be like the
competition starts from the greeting in
the meeting you know I think what the
prize is beauty contest he didn't share
my whole story so what's going to happen
the inside fight video right what I'm
talking about is when you see like the
fighter like you see John Jones right
he's like petting his dog holding his
baby you see the same [ __ ] you see the
guy petting his dog [ __ ] holding his
baby and then when he goes to its [ __ ]
there's like such a [ __ ] dog haha
that's his version of the speed balance
they're in a speed bag dude if the
clitoris playing and then he goes back
to him you know man I was tired and then
hey I hate when I have to go to [ __ ]
competition because I ask you I see my
family for three months at a time and
they're training and San Bernardino
Mountains for oxygen deprivation yeah
same [ __ ] high level athlete it is I
hate it it's not even dislike I hate it
god damn it it's so much passion because
and now you guys know passion you know
the backstory y'all know he's the one I
make her crawl last six months you know
a passion you don't wanna make em come
for the past six months so in the end of
the ring and then have their clothes on
as its death to tell each other poetry
all these things in it little they lower
the lights and I finally said they get
to the [ __ ] yeah and you see who gets
to come first
get all the sexperts together and see
who is the best I bet you get a the best
[ __ ] in the world like I'm the
promoter
I'm the Dana White oh you're the 57-ton
I'm not an athlete oh I'm not good like
these guys go on I'm just trying to help
others event together yeah you're a
[ __ ] pervert
there are such things as competitive
[ __ ]
races see and I could you got to look
good up here there's no way that that is
something that people haven't made up
already because I've been a big fan
inside fighting your your level is like
whatever this right right now that's
just backyard wrestling what we're
trying to do is make some WWE [ __ ]
imagine
at the [ __ ] Mandalay Bay yeah that's
all we're part of live at the MGM ultra
magic Gary I didn't click on excite I
want to look at porn okay I'll just [ __ ]
that it's the ultimate [ __ ] and then
when it gets to next next level like
Mayweather McGregor
now you're gonna McGregor fighting the
ultimate [ __ ] oh trying to [ __ ] while
the other person trying to fight if you
can water it a bit [ __ ] getting
really genius I do some of the later
discussions I'm going to make the time
what does a little life hey guys I hope
you enjoyed that as a set of just
kidding news and if there's a story that
you guys want us to talk about go ahead
down into our description box below and
there's a link there where you can
submit articles for the next video click
right up here
[Music]